hello I would like to do three
days ago I made a video on the subject that
I consider very important such as that
of the mistakes made
when speaking other languages and I wanted to do it in
Italian too because given the somew
at poor quality of the previous video I cer
ainly wanted to  do it in another
language for the no to do it again in Udinese
so today's topic concerns
the mistakes that are made when
trying to speak a foreign language
I believe that making mistakes is a
fundamental aspect of the
cognitive process every time  that we try to
do something to take something to be
able to speak it well we have to make a
series of mistakes from the mistakes we learn and
according to scientific research for
example the monkeys themselves who are
let's say the closest animals to us
learn not only making mistakes but also
observing other monkeys
make mistakes
the difference between humans and
apes is the fact that we can
also have one  ability to reason
to think about our olives
basically both both
monkeys and humans we give them
to learn we learn to live when
it comes to mistakes there is always there is to
know negative feelings that are
involved because mistakes and this is
the  main problem
let's just say very often seen as an
insurmountable problem or something that
can prevent us from the first one on the one hand
this is true we all went to
school we all learned something by
following the lessons and trying to
produce something and being corrected the
main problem is that a
language schools are seen as another
subject to learn to study instead of
a useful tool for
communication purposes to understand the world even better
and to have a horizon
broadening horizons
the main problem that exists in
this school context a certain way
almost more  reason we all need to be
assessed teachers have been assessed
gods harm  vote to greet us and their
task the problem is that when they
go there we often feel almost punished
as if taking the lengths was a
performance
this has generated over time in
our mind, consciously or
unconsciously, a sensation of
negative sensations that are
maintained  when, for
example, in real life we try to suppo
t complaints from nativ
speakers and in a certain way we ke
p enjoying this negat
ve burden I am not only talking about you in gener
l but I also talk about himself about what
appened at school in th
s  way of seeing things
usually also in the forums you see there
often comments here one says to the one there
has an almost perfect accent I do not speak
of in the maps in general of how
people evaluate the or for example the
performance and quality of the
others
that guy speaks with a near-
perfect accent perfect his grammar
speaks the language perfectly or
speaks there  to language in a poor way
this this choice of this
terminology in a certain way suggests
that the wheels people cons I will consider
consider languages almost as a perfo
mance and this often comes from the fact
hat we have learned I have learned to be
evaluated in this way that is we ar
been used to thinking that
Europe we speak must necessarily
be judged
and this
is basically a negative aspect we say of the
whole matter
now I would like to point out that when
we consider marriage in this
model as those who
speak the language perfectly
because yes  they use these derbies it is
necessary to consider the fact that ma de
luca have made countless mistakes
before coming to speak a
language correctly they
have been in the family they have been
current by their parents but in July I
do not think that the corrections made by
the Tesino's parents have so much a
weight but not that relevant
though  if we give the entire path of a
native speaker suppose an eighteen year old and
leaves school it is easy to see how
native speakers have learned the language at
a certain level
thanks to the environment of the parents
certainly but also to the phoenix environment
even having received a
formal education  that the scholastic one and has
therefore passed on the one hand there is an
exposure in massive quotation marks
the language listen listen
write etcetera etcetera listen but
on the other hand there is also another
relevant aspect that that of corrections
in the sense that when we went to
school  for example in our own
language we have been corrected several
times because we have produced a series
of things and we have been evaluated on
those six precisely by one bank
negative contact from the other but always in the
same language it helped us to
improve it I remember that when I had  18
10 years old
he writes very well in Italian I think
this negative impact on
middle school the prima la  sixth grade and
my teacher had told me
that he had to improve in some way to
engage a little frustrated because I
did not know how to do it
I started on the one hand to read
it right in particular to the books
of the famous game books that
helped me the massive reading of books
started to have an impact a
positive effect but on the other hand or even
developed a positive
attitude towards corrections I wanted to
be corrected every time someone
corrected my profession in red
sorry for the red and blue pen
I wrote him all corrections  this too
has helped to
improve my written Italian the
best Italian my oral Italian
so when we talk about a
system in which native speakers are the
model they are yes on the model side but
no one in the world is
perfect languages even if they are invalsi  we recommend
impact more in language is a
complex system that over all changes changes
continuously  and no one able to
dominate a language is used on you
also often hear this concept of dominating
a language does not exist because no one was
valid domina but the woman enough to
be able to communicate with others this is
the most important concept in my opinion
we need to think and conceive  long
queues an imperfect means of communication
because no one was for
perfection there is not only an
image that we have that we use or
almost to be able to judge others
when they speak and we are afraid of it when it
is our turn to speak to oneself therefore
on the one hand  mistakes are inevitable
on the other hand there is this negative feeling
let's suppose for example that I think it
happened to almost all of you to try to
speak at the beginning and to be corrected
and to try these rather annoying corrections
I would like to give you some guidelines
what  i think general advice on
how to improve
using mistakes so mistakes
are inevitable but poss  we use them they
can become our best
friends our best friends first
of all find a
what is termed english
online fan there is a person to
exchange languages with if yo
live in a big city its not that hard
n the internet  for example you can
find many announcements there are
also contri that are organized in
general to see people face
to face to be able to make
disputes a bar where
these meetings are organized but if you
live instead the most remote places in
quotation marks there is always the internet
always exists  sky which is a real
revolution for those who have learned to use it
at the end of learning the news of
course skype is a means so the
person to choose is very important
especially when as I said before
you are trying to talk about the first
steps and meet a person  than to
correct a 30 seconds and
blows your urge to speak from the mountain
because s  it almost seems that I want to
impose on you and I want to make you feel not at
ease I want to make you feel uncomfortable
so it is important to choose a
person who you think like you who is
also her or him passionate
languages is not so difficult to find for examp
e there is  a site called had
dhabi there by you I have to succeed the top
organ point where you can find
many native speakers who are willing
to do mystical exchanges so finding it is
true that unpleasant people exist
are candidates for all but
most of the people you will find  on
this
site thinks like you and it could help you
enormously and naturally find a
person who has similar interests
and this is one of the most important things
when deciding on
a trip like this that is to
start talking to proxy another second
fundamental point is to expand  and
to refine when we talk about listening
and reading
we talk about linguistic expansion we talk about espa
tourism nsion in the sense that we are
expanding our knowledge
through the acquisition of structures
through the acquisition of speech but
as I said before there is also another
parallel track which is that of
refinement air reliance is obtained
thanks to human interaction
if on the one hand  reading and listening are
two fundamental components on the other hand
human interaction and cooperation
with other people are fundamental
all native speakers have cooperated
and interacted with others with
parents with friends with professors
to get to be able to speak as he
speaks  so if on the one hand reading
listening has become easier
and easier with the internet thanks to technology,
refinement is something we can do
also and above all thanks to the
collaboration and cooperation with
someone, an advice is for
example to record the lessons you
do on skype if for  example you are
talking to someone obviously you have
dif  Difficulty managing a speech in a
language you don't know because
our brains of yours
in everyone's have to do with
a boundless series of factors think about
the syntax think about the word about the
pronunciation the intonation what you want to
say a meaning and  so clearly
this will lead you to make many more
mistakes many mistakes but a
positive thing is to be corrected
after having made a little speech and
above all as I said to record the
lesson so that once
the recorded lesson veils you can
listen with  great karl your
brain will not have to say a thing to
do with so many factors but only
with that of listening and trying to
self correct you to listen to the
collections of the person
claims this is something that I have been
using used for two years with
pension however I work  for example in
the Polish bus and is from Udine until 8 to
brings sensational benefits
another thing that  the third point is that
as I said before, languages are made to co
municate if you choose topic
that interest you even if you don't have
arts I lack words you w
ll have this boundless desire to commu
icate this idea someone is also where
enough words will remain it is easy
o obtain  because it is enough
simply to ask her you must never be
ashamed to know something to
ask directly but how do you say
that then try to continue and
possibly ask if you do not know
other things but choosing the
topics you are passionate about makes a big
difference instead of choosing the usual ones
hackneyed arguments or pretending
to be at the station or going to the
post office which are most often the
introductory lessons of many courses and the fourth
is perhaps the fourth point is perhaps the most
important is to maintain a
positive attitude
whenever  you are corrected not
only is
the mistake your friend but it is something
more that he has learned  that in it which
he has forfeited in the brain therefore
implies that even
if one of the situations are
composed let's say hilarious it is an
important thing to maintain a
positive attitude even where it is corrected
in a way a little let's say snooty for
example there is  a friend who still lives in
Paris who told me she speaks a
lot of French dog almost with a
mother tongue mother now did not
tell me that several years ago when
she knew French well but did not
yet know the subtleties of the stop language it
concerns a boy and  at the end of the
evening
she asks him about civilizations for example in
French bizet does not mean kissing the
custom she thought of third hand and
kissing while instead occupying what
we say is quite another thing
this guy who has stayed a while in Rome
says he is thrilled is  was very surprised and
then I love rice together so living
together with mistakes so that she
will never forget is important and makes par  you
of learning is part of an
important cognitive process to laugh at it
because we are all wrong I would like to complete
this speech by quoting einstein
a person I respect very much but I think
that almost everyone hosting and he said
all those who have never made a
mistake have not  never tried anything
new
thank you so much